je mentirais si je disais que la vie ne
m'a pas donné d'enfants ce sont tous mes
enfants
voici quelques uns des artistes qui sont
passés par ici ces dernières années vous
êtes impatients de rencontrer vos
camarades
miranda est une jeune styliste tellement
talentueuse qu'elle est capable de
concevoir jour vers mac est le reflet de
l'âme de la personne qui le porte
enfin des copines j'avais l'impression
d'être fille unique la petite préférée
d'isabela alors maintenant g3 petit
préféré ou saura où les soldes en bas on
va les retrouver
raul est en train de projeter les
visuels qui l'a créé vous repousser les
limites de la réalité pour qu'elle ne se
résume pas uniquement une chose qu'on
peut toucher et voici sol producteur et
organisateur de concerts lui c'est raul
et lui c'est son jeu ne sait déjà plus
petit nom